I felt a great disturbance in the force
as if millions of fanboys suddenly cried
out in anger they were never silenced I
[Applause]
[Music]
fear something terrible has happened
okay so here's the main thing I was
gonna talk about um so something very
weird happened and I ignored it
initially and then it got confirmed like
no this is for real with independent
verification from fairly reliable
sources and yeah so a pretty dang
detailed breakdown of what was callin
Trevor O's plan for Star Wars Episode
nine basically got out exactly how I
don't know this is an immediately
curious artifact because regardless of
what you think about Star Wars Episode
nine finding out what it was intended to
be at an earlier point it's just
interesting so like that's cool here's
one thing I am NOT gonna go point for
point through this thing I'm not gonna
give you the full breakdown there are
other folks who have done that I will
link to sources below if you want just
all the plot points I will talk I'm not
going to assume that you do already know
them I will talk about each one that I
wish to discuss just understand don't
come to me for the comprehensive list of
everything and now the other thing to
keep in mind before I talk about this is
this would have been the plan when
Trevor or when Trevor Oh was going to
direct which also means it was the plan
when Carrie Fisher was still alive
so while I'm sure there are plenty of
people who are going to look at this and
go Abrams threw it out this story as it
was presented couldn't be done anyway or
at least huge swathe
love it couldn't be done because Carrie
Fisher died and so you can't just assume
this is the movie we would have had this
was the plan before the one-two punch of
Carrie Fisher dying and then Trevor OH
leaving the project and again the exact
nature of that still seems iffy to me in
terms of why exactly it happened my my
assumption had always been that he
didn't have a ton of time to rework the
story that he had after Carrie Fisher
had died and he couldn't crack in that
amount of time what he was gonna do with
it so he either bailed or they asked him
to leave or possibly both I know there's
I know there are things that have been
said and this and that but like that was
always kind of the assumption that I
went with this plot honestly while
Carrie Fisher is important in it and
obviously they couldn't have still done
this plan with her parts intact because
they couldn't shoot her stuff with her
she's not as prominent as I would have
expected at least not in the not in the
breakdown as As Seen and some of the sub
like the major major major fundamental
things are not the same so here's the
first thing that this basically confirms
that the making of rise of Skywalker was
not the result of two films worth of
build-up it was the result of a fairly
tightly scheduled massive upheaval and
rewrite so the big things to bring up
here or I would add the two big things
to bring up spoilers for rise of
Skywalker
I guess warning I don't know if I still
need to be given that but first Rey
remains nobody in this plot outline and
Palpatine doesn't come back which means
that Rey Palpatine definitively and
we've kind of had this
indication up to this point but
definitively was not planned and was not
some grand master scheme and the Emperor
coming back things were not all building
to that now that does not need to
inherently undermine the value of rise
of Skywalker if you took enjoyment from
it
the fact that it wasn't planned to be
defer that film to always be those
things doesn't mean the film loses value
I still enjoyed the movie for the most
part I did enjoy the Palpatine thing I
didn't like that race Rey was his
granddaughter so funnily enough those
things specifically I actually didn't
like but you know lots of people I
suspect and I have been avoiding the
discourse that it and that I'm sure is
swirling around all this because I don't
want to set off a migraine but I don't
doubt that there are plenty of people
who are going see it was never supposed
to be that therefore rise of Skywalker's
terrible well no those are completely
unrelated things if these specific
issues that you have with rise of
Skywalker kind of get explained by the
fact that well this wasn't planned which
in my for me is kind of the case with
some of the issues I have with that film
that's one thing but to simply now go
the movie is garbage and has no value
because it wasn't part of a plan like do
you know how late into the game Marvel
didn't have a plan and how much they
continue to make up as they go they're
just a lot better at stitching it
together then Star Wars has been so like
that in and of itself doesn't remove
value from Rises Skywalker and it's
funny I actually I ran right up on this
that presents it like Colin trevorrose
planned film was awesome and we were
robbed of it and I went through this
plot summary I went okay some of this
stuff is
decent idea some of it builds more
directly off the last Jedi so if you
like the last item more than I did it
probably would have appealed to you but
there's other songs I'm like no that's
dumb I'm not sure it's as done as dumb
as Palpatine coming back but it ain't
good so I I also feel like people who
don't like rides of Skywalker are going
to oversell this thing oh for God's sake
if this begins a petition of it wouldn't
heat it couldn't even be released at
Trevor okay cuz this script wasn't shot
but if if this if we start seeing a
petition for shoot The Trevor Oh cut I'm
going oh I'm gonna throw something
probably something soft because I don't
want to break stuff but you know the
frustration anyways so aside from the
fact that Rey remains nobody in
Palpatine doesn't come back sort of he
does he's not back from the dead or
whatever the hell he actually was in
Raisa Skywalker he does make an
appearance in this plot
oh the working title was duel of the
fates so we'll let's let's call it that
going forward he was going to appear but
as part of a holocron as a message not
actually still being alive which if they
were gonna shoot him in there I would
much rather they had done that so points
for that there as far as the first order
that actually gets a little bit detached
it actually in many ways that this plot
pulls a Return of the Jedi which is to
say the force users the people who wear
lightsabers they have their plot and
then the rebellion and the Empire in
Return of the Jedi first order in this
case have their plot and rarely the
twain shall meet
so that seems to be much more how it was
constructed with Rey and kylo Ren being
built up and in this thing apparently
Hawkes is leading the first order
because at the end of last Jedi as far
as they were concerned kylo Ren went off
did his own thing but the first order
still is there somebody's got to run it
he's running it um I think I would add
well depending on execution that might
take some people off because nobody
likes Huck's except for me
I think he's great as I'd like he's a
terrible person I think he's a great
character honest to God but um the whole
thing was that was going to be dealt
with with the first order was that they
basically did a communications blackout
across the galaxy so now the planets
can't communicate with each other in the
interest of not letting the story of
what Luke Skywalker did and standing up
to the first order in you know and the
tail end of the last Jedi
they don't want that story to spread and
like inspire hope and rebellion and
resistance so that that's that and so
the the resistance is main thrust in the
main thing that they're after is finding
a way to get a message out through this
communications blackout
- then rally the galaxy to pull together
which is while the whole communications
blackout thing is new is not vastly
dissimilar from what end up being pulled
in rise of the Jedi effectively now
granted it was Palpatine and his
bajillion start destroyers with Death
Star lasers that's dumb but it's like
it's kind of fun dumb but anyways you
know but the way that gets taken on is
Lando basically manages to rally the
entire rest of the galaxy so there's
still that idea of they need to rally
everybody else or they're doomed that
appears in both stories so there's that
with kylo Ren so what they did with him
and they dropped the redemption for Ben
which here's what I'm gonna say I'm
slightly iffy on because his trajectory
and his character in his art and his
Redemption and his connection with Rey
was actually I thought a lot of the best
stuff in rise of Skywalker so while I'm
not gonna say that duel of the fates
would have done it worse I'm much less
confident in replacing the stuff that I
really liked because
the duel of the fates would have had to
have done it extremely well for me to
enjoy they fail to bring him back to the
light side and he dies and make me enjoy
that as much as I enjoyed his Redemption
and coming back to the light side in
rise of Skywalker it would be very hard
for them to do that but what he does and
this is where the emperor comes into
play in this thing he finds a holocron
and the Emperor directs him to hang on I
gotta look up the name of this guy so
the Emperor's hologram directs kylo Ren
to Palpatine's old master tor Vallum
seven thousand year old Sith and kylo
Ren goes to him for training oh and
apparently when he goes to is all a
Mustafar which was Vader's home base
it's the lava place so kylo Ren goes
there to try and find this holocron and
get this message and Luke's force ghost
is following him and taunting him the
whole way which I don't feel about that
it's interesting I'll give it that
but then kylo Ren goes in trains with
this guy now I've got a couple problems
with this first of all I have no doubt
that this guy is in the lore somewhere
and expanded bla bla bla bla
I will I've said it before I'll say it
again I don't care I shouldn't have to
do homework to know who these people are
in the films this guy's never been
mentioned like the only others the only
Sith
to predate Palpatine that has ever been
named checked was Darth Plagueis and
this is not that this is something else
now that said I will say that what notes
are in there about how this thing was
intended to be designed was kinda cool
like the word Lovecraftian got bandied
about and this sort of very
the worldly being that was sort of
really channels and embodies the dark
side of the force
I'm kind of curious to have seen what
that would have looked like that would
have been cool but there's something
about like basically this massive dark
side force that is so powerful that it
trained the guy who up to this point we
thought was the end-all be-all of fifth
power and we've a never heard of him
before and B he's never taken an active
role in any of this I there may be an
explanation but my immediate question is
why don't you take action if you care
about the light side dark side thing and
if you don't care why are you training
anybody I don't know it brings up
immediate questions which the new
trilogy has been very bad at answering
the questions that tend to be its own
plots tend to ring up and I keep saying
to some things you can gloss over some
things I'm not sure you can and that
would be kind of a big question a little
bit of a big plot hole if they were to
do that but that's apparently the the
whole thing for kylo Ren so what last
part in this whole thing was gonna be
she was apparently gonna do two things
she was gonna rally the you know the
Armada to come and take on the first
order so that you know she was going to
be the general general Leia makes sense
um general Organa you listen to her and
you do what she says and the other thing
was that she did not believe that Ben
could be saved
whereas Rey did which if properly
executed the idea that Rey thought he
could be redeemed but realize at the end
he can't and he dies that can pay off
well hard needle to thread but it could
work like in many ways giving
kylo ren's some kind of redemptive art
is the easier emotional weight to bring
to everything having him having the hope
die is a harder thing to do well I mean
you can do just compared revenge of the
system revenge of the sister Return of
the Jedi and it's not just about one
being an upper one being a downer you
know one is just better executed than
the other because it's easier triumph
triumph is not the easiest thing in the
world to do extremely well but triumph
is a little bit easier to give audiences
a satisfying thing then everything falls
apart and I mean it wouldn't be like I
suppose it would depend on whether or
not they like really go all in him like
he's bad and every Dima bull I'm where
they go with that so or would have gone
with that rather um there there was
there was some other stuff about the way
that the resistance was going to get the
message out there was some sort of
beacon in the old Jedi Temple which is
underneath core Assam which is
controlled by the first order so that
whole thing not vastly dissimilar to all
this sort of sneaking around the first
order that was actually in rise of the
Skywalker there it was about you know
finding these little map things so like
locations were different and things but
like general tone not a million miles
off as far as that subplot goes um also
doesn't look like rose was gonna be who
was gonna be effectively written out in
this so there's that she was actually
gonna be you know part of a group that
that had a mission but overall I look at
this and go I see some of the things
here that I'm not sure are great ideas
but are better than the ones that were
done in rises of Skywalker and then
there are other things that I see that
I'm like there are actually elements of
rise of Skywalker that I really like and
I worry that this would yet this doing
something else wouldn't have done the
other thing as good as the good stuff in
rise of Skywalker again specifically
talking about
and Ben and Rafe and impose their group
dynamic collectively because again as
planned this original this duel of the
fates would have split the group again
I'm really annoyed by that actually they
really didn't seem to understand how
good these three actors had chemistry
together but it's kind of an interesting
interesting thing to find out and to
think about it to speculate as long as
people don't like start to get stupid
about it which I'm sure they will and
already have but yeah be either based
off what you've read or what you've just
heard me ramble what do you think about
this theoretical alternate episode 9
that was the original plan whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it you can
also support me immensely by going to my
patreon there are many many tiers
including as little as a dollar a month
and it is a huge help but even if you
can't spare me the change you can like
you since you can subscribe you can
share this around all of which are
wonderfully helpful
plus there's less other stuff below I've
got an Instagram for a council of geeks
now there isn't much on it but it exists
so you know there's that there's other
stuff besides click on things or I mean
you don't I'm not gonna tell you what to
do I can't Jedi mind-trick you to do my
bidding much as I might wish it I would
so spam that ability but yeah I mean at
the end of the day you're the council
I'm just around the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned you
will like share and subscribe
oh my freaking God okay so like I
completely missed talking about a couple
of things so all right apparently they
added in a thing or they would have
added in a thing where yeah I said raise
pant rate was still nobody in our
parents or nobody but for no particular
reason it's revealed that kylo Ren
killed them that's stupid and completely
unnecessary like what the heck does that
gain and they were gonna have it and
with a raid beginning to train the next
generation of force users including
Broome kid from the end of the previous
movie that's a nice tie-in with that cuz
otherwise the moment that the last Jedi
ended on honestly it kind of hangs there
like an appendix as it stands right now
so yeah I thought to add this a day
later ie the day before this goes up ie
I got a now add re-edit the crap out of
this thing so yeah yeah got a call at
least
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]